we've got some breaking news for you and
i'm very sorry to tell you that we've
just learned that retired general colin
powell has died of covet 19
complications the former secretary of
state and one time chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff was 84 years old powell
was a groundbreaking figure in
washington the son of jamaican
immigrants who rose to become the first
black man to hold those two positions
president george h.w bush chose powell
to be the nation's top general and he
held that position during the first gulf
war a decade later president george w
bush appointed him to be secretary of
state nancy cordes is at the white house
with more nancy boy i was very very
sorry we just got this news
and gail it really is a blow and we'll
be here in washington very keenly felt
here is a man who was so highly
respected by both sides and really
strove to have an independent voice here
in washington well respected around the
country in a statement from his family
this morning we are learning that he
passed away this morning due to
complications from covet 19. they say he
was fully vaccinated they thanked the
medical staff at walter reed national
medical center for caring treatment so
that is apparently where he was they say
they have lost a remarkable and loving
husband
father grandfather and a great american
an american who as you mentioned gail
served at the highest ranks of this
government at the pentagon considered
running for president and at times was
urged to do that by not just democrats
but republicans as well who held him in
such high
esteem nancy thank you so much you're so
right to point out that he was really as
we all know widely respected on both
sides of the aisle our thoughts go to
his wife of course he has two sons and a
daughter and grandchildren this was just
it just goes to show you how you wake up
you think it's going to be a normal day
and then you get news like this that
just sort of knocks you off center a
little bit but colin powell we're just
learning dead at the age of 84
from complications of co but of course
we'll have more on this story throughout
the day